MALE SPEAKER: So welcome
to Talks at Google,
to this afternoon we're
very thrilled to host
Greg Ferenstein, who is a
former political journalist
for TechCrunch, where,
among his other skills,
he taught mathematics to
journalists, which is always
an important thing to do.
And he's here
speaking to us today
about his latest thesis,
which arose out of some Medium
posts and some articles for
TechCrunch, "Silicon Valley's
Political End Game,"
so this strange mixture
of libertarianism and
progressivism we have here.
And what does that mean?
Where is it going?
How does it impact the local
and national issues we face?
So with that, please join me
in welcoming Greg to Google.
Thanks.
GREGORY FERENSTEIN:
Thanks for having me.
I think I kind of want
to thank you guys,
because I think 70% of all
of my internet experience
is at Google itself--
Google Docs, Google,
Google Maps, everything.
My internet experience
and digital life
is basically Google.
So thank you.
I appreciate it, guys.
In 1981, the "Ottawa Citizen"
newspaper reported on a story
from a University of
Carelton professor
who claimed that if "teachers
don't stand up to the growing
invasion of computers
in the classroom,
there's a good
chance that literacy
will disappear in 10 years."
Obviously, these were
not prophetic words.
When I first began researching
the politics and philosophy
of breakthrough innovators,
I started with what I knew
wasn't.
And I knew it wasn't pessimism.
You would dedicate
your life to trying
to improve the future if you
thought the outlook was bleak.
And indeed, when I then
began systematically
to interview
breakthrough innovators
about their philosophy,
what was core to them,
first and foremost,
above all else,
they describe
themselves as optimists.
We're working with two
different devices here.
Wikipedia founder,
Jimmy Wales, "I'm
a pathologically
optimistic person."
Mark Zuckerberg,
"I'm an optimist.
I think you need to be,
to be an entrepreneur."
"I may be the most
optimistic person I know.
I mean I'm incredibly
optimistic.
I'm optimistic,
arguably, to a fault,
especially in terms of new
idea," Marc Andreessen.
Steve Jobs, "I'm an
optimist in the sense
that I believe humans are noble
and honorable, and some of them
are really smart.
I have a very optimistic
view of individuals."
At first, I dismissed
this optimism
as just kind of like hippie
frou-frou Silicon Valley.
But then I learned
this optimism was just
a rhetorical wrapper around very
specific business strategies
and political policies.
The motivation
originally behind this
was that technologists,
all of a sudden,
are becoming very influential,
at least according to "Forbes."
Over 80% of billionaires on
the Forbes 400 list under 40
come from technology.
So whatever these
folks believe is
going to exert an extraordinary
amount of influence
over the future.
So I wanted to answer
three questions.
One, does the optimism of
information technologists
have a unique worldview?
Is it just that they're
good at technology
and they happened
to do politics,
or are they somehow combined?
Does this worldview help
them make technology?
That is, is there something
about their politics
and their vision
for the future that
is behind and almost
a prerequisite
for billion-dollar ideas?
And the last is,
is this worldview
shared by just a small number
of very rich and very successful
people, or is it part of a
broader political movement?
The answer to all of
these, I think, is yes.
And because I'm
attention deficit
and I assume my
audience is too, I
will just go ahead and tell
you my thesis before I go on
with the explanation.
The world has
gotten more complex.
As a result, it's given rise
to the knowledge economy.
The knowledge
economy has empowered
a novelty-seeking
personality that
has an extreme optimism
in information alone
to solve problems.
This is built on a
growing demographic
of college-educated,
urbanized professionals, who
represent an entirely
new political category.
They are pro-government
and pro-market
but believe the
government's role isn't
to regulate capitalism, but
to invest in capitalism,
to accelerate change
by investing directly
in citizens to be more educated,
entrepreneurial, and civic.
If you take away nothing
else, very simple, betting
that information
will make the future
has become a very
profitable belief system.
And that essentially
is why optimists
will inherit the earth.
The rest is explanation.
So starting with
the first question,
what do these folks believe?
The best explanation
actually came
from the patron of this
organization, Eric Schmidt.
He said, "there's a particular
religion that we all represent,
and it goes something like this.
If you take a large
number of people
and you empower them
with communication tools
and opportunities to be
created, society gets better.
The combination of empowerment,
innovation, and creativity
will be will be our solution.
And that is a religion
in-of-itself."
So the folks who make
breakthrough technologies
and help them along
are cognizant that they
have a distinct world view.
So when I delved deeper into
Eric's and other people's idea
that somehow citizens,
just through empowerment,
could make the world
a better place,
I found that their philosophy
was founded on two main ideas.
First, as Reid Hoffman
told me, "if you're
working towards
progress, your future
will be better
than your present."
That is change is
inherently good.
The very nature of change
makes things better.
Now, change can often be
bad over the short term.
You can have a bad
20 or 30 years even.
But eventually, if
you just keep trying,
if you just keep
changing and disrupting,
eventually things get better.
This is the first
tenant of optimism,
or at least described
by Silicon Valley.
So then I took
what I was learning
from Reid Hoffman and
other folks, and I said,
is this just the very
wealthy in Silicon Valley,
or is it technologists
more broadly?
So I'm a former writer for a
tech blog called TechCrunch.
They have a database of every
single startup founder ever.
I found their email addresses
and randomly emailed
them to take a battery of
40 political psychology
questions, which
became what I think
is the first representative
political opinion poll of what
Silicon Valley believes.
And I peppered them with
some of these statements.
Indeed, when you ask, is change
inherently good or productive
over the long term,
80% of tech founders
say yes-- near unanimity.
That number is unheard of in
political opinion polling.
You rarely get numbers that big.
When I compare
that same question
to a survey done of the general
population, only 48% of people
agreed that change inherently
over the long run is good.
Now, this gets into why
the Valley's generally
kind of considered libertarian--
this kind of free market
ideology, anything goes.
Let's change as
quickly as possible.
When you compare tech
founders with Libertarians
and Democrats, they
look like Libertarians
on a couple big issues.
They're not as big a
fans of labor unions.
They tend to believe that
labor unions, especially
teachers unions, tend to
protect the status quo
and prevent organizations from
experimenting and piloting
new things and moving into
the future very quickly.
So about 29% of
tech founders think
that labor unions are
good for the economy,
and 21% of Libertarians.
On the flip side,
they're radically
pro-free trade-- NAFTA, TPP.
They want capitalism everywhere.
And that's where this myth that
the Silicon Valley is generally
Libertarian comes from.
That would be true, except for
the fact that Silicon Valley,
as a whole, is arguably the
most liberal industry on planet
Earth.
83% of donations in the
2012 presidential election
from top tech firms, like
Google, Facebook, and Amazon,
went to Obama
versus Romney-- 83%.
If you look at all
donations back to 2008
from every single tech
founder and investor,
63% went to Democrats.
In my survey of tech
founders, about 7%
identify as Republican.
So clearly, if we
want to understand
what tech founders
and Silicon Valley
believes, thinking that
they're Libertarian
was missing something.
Why are they such a big fan
of the Democratic party?
And this I learned,
when a Libertarian icon
in the Senate, Rand
Paul, announced
his presidential candidacy
and came to San Francisco.
And he got up on stage.
He was really excited.
He wanted to warm up the
crowd, and he led with this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Is there anybody out here from
the leave-me-alone coalition?
Not that many.
[END PLAYBACK]
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: Right?
He said, is anyone out here from
the leave-me-alone coalition?
No one clapped, and
it was really awkward.
Leave me alone, get
government out of my life
is central to the
Libertarian philosophy.
And yet it was not
popular in San Francisco.
This led me to do
some more questioning.
So one of the central
tenants of Libertarianism
is that there is a
conflict between government
and citizens.
On the flipside,
Democrats tend to believe
that there's a conflict between
citizens and big corporations.
The richer corporations
get, the less citizens have.
Tech founders, as a
group, overwhelmingly
believe that there's is no
conflict between business,
corporations, or citizens.
At 61%, they say everyone
has a role in society,
and they can all work
together, compared to just 20%
of the public.
They have an optimism
that collectivism
and interdependence is possible.
When I dug deeper
into that theory,
I learned that a popular term
in the Valley is what's called
"non-zero sum economy--"
a non-zero sum economy.
The idea that you can build
things that benefit people.
Even if some people
benefit a little bit more,
you raise the tide for everyone.
The core of this
popular non-zero sum
meme in Silicon
Valley is that what
is good for you is good for me.
What is bad for you
is also bad for me.
So I asked this question,
does everything people
do, including their
personal decisions,
like whether to be
educated or eat healthy,
affect enough other
people to justify
government intervention?
A near majority, 49% of
founders believed that.
Only 20% of Libertarians
and 60% of Democrats.
That is they think
interdependence
is part of society,
that we are connected.
And so now we have a working
definition of optimism.
There is always
a better solution
that benefits more people.
I think most reasonable
people, at this point,
would be asking
themselves, what is
the connection between
technology and politics?
You've shown me a
lot of correlations.
But what do the two have
to do with each other?
I kind of want to
make the case to you
that technology is if not
mostly political, inherently
political.
If you build a missile,
you build it for a reason.
You're trying to
protect the country.
Hawkish people, who are
fearful of other countries
or terrorists, build
military technologies.
If any of you guys
know any Bitcoin folks,
the anonymous
crypto currency that
is an alternative to
money, the community
started out hyper Libertarian.
They wanted to free the
economy from the confines
of the government and its
control over the cash supply
So what I did is I
found a way to predict
someone's political ideology
from the products they built.
I looked at every single public
political donation, Federal
Elections Commission, and I
matched that to tech founders.
And I found that,
indeed-- you might have
troubles reading the slide.
But this is the
political orientation
grouped by startup category.
If you work in finance,
in cyber security,
you're more likely to
be a hawkish Republican
or a Libertarian, which is
kind of what we thought.
The most liberal category
in all of startup land,
or one of them,
social networking.
Why is that the case?
Why is a social network
political at all?
And that's what I
find fascinating,
because the actual
politics of Silicon
Valley and technologists
and tech workers
are so distinct from our
traditional categories,
we don't even recognize
that a social network has,
in fact, a policy analog.
The way I want to show you that
is the differences between My
Space and Facebook.
If you can remember all the
way back in internet history,
back to 2006, My Space
was king of kings.
And they had an idea
that social networking
was about expression.
On the left here, you
see-- or it's you're right.
You see a My Space page.
You could do whatever you want.
You could make it annoying.
You could have auto play music.
My Space didn't care.
They encouraged this.
When pornographic
stars were kicked off
of earlier social networks,
they invited them on My Space.
Do whatever you want.
It is a Libertarian
expression paradise.
And the culture of
their users ate it up.
There was a phrase that went
viral, before we kind of knew
what viral meant, in 2006
on My Space that said,
"don't judge me."
This is what people plastered
all over their profiles.
It was so popular
that it spawned
its own kind of gaudy t-shirt
and like rhinestone, the
Don't Judge Me t-shirt line.
Zuckerberg and co had
a different philosophy.
Zuckerberg said,
"on My Space people
got to do whatever they
wanted on their profile.
We always thought
people would share more,
if we didn't let them
do whatever they wanted,
because we gave
them some order."
Facebook had a North Star.
Sheryl Sandberg,
"Mark really does
believe very much
in transparency
and the vision of an open
society and an open world,
and so he wants to
push people that way."
So one of the early
things that Facebook did
was they did auto
tagging of photos,
and they eventually turned
that into the newsfeed.
And if you remember, there
was a massive backlash.
Zuckerberg personally
had to make
a statement on the
front page of Facebook,
or in people's [INAUDIBLE].
He's like, I get it.
You're worried about privacy.
You're worry about
what's going on.
But we have this
vision for the world,
and we're going to continue
doing the newsfeed.
And we're going
to continue trying
to push people to
share more information,
because he believed--
and this is often
made fun-- that just getting
people to share cat videos
or what they're
doing at a wedding
or what they believe
or an article, just
sharing information was a way to
make the world a better place.
Doesn't seem very political.
We know it is because one
of Facebook's first users
was this guy, Harvard University
Professor Robert Putnam.
Putnam became famous for
this idea of social capital.
It's a theory that says
the best way to improve
the governance of a city,
to make people healthier,
to make economies more equal,
to make the bureaucracy more
efficient is simply to
get people to hangout more
on an informal basis--
bowling leagues,
book clubs, rotary clubs.
He found this in a
25-year-long study of Italy.
And he wanted to know why
some sections in the north,
like Amelia, were
much more prosperous
and equal and healthy.
And after 25 years of
studying every variable
in political science, he
found one simple pattern.
In the north, there
was more community.
Specifically, people
just hung out more.
That simple fact
of Northern Italy
made them a much better society.
And now governments around the
world-- sometimes with the UN--
it is a policy, a public policy,
to get people to hang out
more on an informal basis.
Social capital as
a political theory
has been replicated
dozens of times, sometimes
experimentally.
They find out if you
share informal things,
things get better.
Facebook was the technological
manifestation of that policy,
and a rather optimistic
policy at that.
You want the world
to get better?
Just have people talk more.
Ultimately, it's an
informational philosophy.
People share information
about government services
or what people are doing wrong
or right in their neighborhood,
and they also exchange empathy.
They get to know each other.
So if Silicon Valley
represents an entirely new
political category,
people often ask me,
what does this look like in
an actual policy, modern day?
Google's backyard,
San Francisco.
One of the distinct
beliefs that I learned
about Silicon Valley
was they believed
that cities, bringing people
to cities, was a moral good.
Often the San Francisco
housing crisis
is often kind of couched
in terms of tech people
just wanting cheaper
rent, and Google
not having that have to pay
higher salaries because that's
the only way that
their workers can
afford to live close to campus.
And if you're not familiar
with the San Francisco housing
crisis, although I
assume most folks in here
are-- or the Bay Area
housing crisis, for those
watching online--
only 8% of housing
is now affordable
in San Francisco
because the city has tried
to protect its suburbs
and won't allow buildings
to get taller or more dense.
They've just
literally restricted
a lot of dense buildings.
Even if you can't buy
a home, median rents
have skyrocketed
about $4,000 a month.
Thousands of people have
been evicted from their homes
from landlords who
see that they can now
sell a relatively inexpensive
home for over $1 million or $2
million.
So as a result, you have
this massive conflict
between technologists and some
renters who want to build more,
and critics who say that
Google and tech companies
and the rest of the creative
class that are coming in just
want to take over the city.
For 6,000 years of
technological history,
cities have been the birth place
for information technology.
Writing likely happened around
the time of Mesopotamia,
when people gathered for the
first time in such large groups
that they began to
have grain surpluses,
and they couldn't account
for what everyone had.
So they had cuneiform
tablets, and they
made little tick marks.
And that's how they
were able to keep track
of who had what food and items.
Complexity,
especially in cities,
is the birthplace of many
information technologies,
and it's been that
way for 6,000 years.
So to believe in
cities isn't just
to believe you
want cheaper rent,
is to believe that
one of the best
things you can do for humanity
is to bring them to cities.
This is what San Francisco looks
like as an affordable city.
That's a simulation I did based
on econometric estimates of San
Francisco with almost double
the housing stock it has now--
200,000 more units.
Now we know that,
I think-- well,
I've made the case that
information technologists,
Silicon Valley, and
urbanized professionals
have a distinct
political category.
And we know what it kind
of looks like in policy.
The title of the talk
is "Why Optimists Will
Inherit the Earth."
It turns out that
the dividing line,
at least within the
Democratic Party,
over people who are more
optimistic about change,
a little bit more
collectivist in orientation,
a bigger fan of free
trade, and investment
orientation of
government happens
to be college education.
The more college
educated you are,
the more you tend to
believe in this philosophy.
Over the last decades,
if you can see the slide,
the share of people voting
in Democratic elections,
or presidential elections
that are Democrats,
are college educated
have grown a lot
and are now the
majority of voters.
This radically
altered the leadership
of at least one party.
The picture you see above
is congressional leadership.
So the blue areas represent
leaders in Congress
who were at one time
very popular, measured
by when they introduce a bill,
a lot of their colleagues sign
on.
It used to be Union County--
the middle of the country.
But as urbanized professionals
and college educated people
went to the cities, it split.
30 years later, the leadership
is now on the coasts,
think Nancy Pelosi in San
Francisco, Hillary Clinton
in New York.
This is how systematically the
people who are most optimistic
built technologies.
They made some money.
They wanted to move to cities.
They became a majority of
voters and large donors.
And at least in one
party, it is now
shifted more towards
that orientation,
towards a more investment
orientation of government.
I'll leave why I
think it's going
to be the most influential.
This is a map of every
major information
technology ever invented,
all the way back
to the Macedonians.
When I began studying the
history and the philosophy
of those who invented
big technologies,
they sounded like
Silicone Valley folks.
Socrates, who, with
Plato and Aristotle,
invented the academy, some of
the first official schooling,
said, there is only
one good, knowledge,
and one evil, ignorance.
Socrates was killed
for that belief.
Centuries later,
Charles Babbage,
who created one of the first
programmable computers,
said, knowledge is power.
Babbage wasn't killed, but
he wasn't a very wealthy man,
and the government,
at the time, decided
not to invest in the project.
They didn't see any
future for a computer.
Sean Parker, founding
president of Facebook,
told me it's the hacker
ethic that a lot of problems
in the world are
information inefficiencies.
And he's a billionaire.
The growing complexity
of the world
will, for the first
time in human history,
allow this very ancient
ideology to become
either the most powerful or
a very powerful influence
over the world.
And that is where optimists
will inherit the earth.
MALE SPEAKER:
Through your research
and through your
interviews, is it
a matter of the sort of big
voices carrying the most
weight?
I'm thinking of the folks
who want to split California
into six different states--
the Libertarian paradise to be
established in
international waters.
How does that impact
the studies you
found with the overall
progressive mentality
of the Silicon Valley?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN:
So I don't know
where the myth that Silicon
Valley was Libertarian
came from.
I suspect it fit into
a kind of narrative,
speaking as a writer.
It was easy to say,
OK, these folks don't
like government regulation.
And they're big
fans of capitalism.
And they also like money.
Therefore they must
be Libertarian.
And so these kind of
like weird projects,
like trying to split
California into six states
or create a floating city
of the coast of California
that doesn't have any US
government regulation,
it fit into that narrative.
And so it was given an
outside voice in the press.
What you didn't
see was, in fact,
that almost all donations
from top tech companies
go to Democrats in
presidential elections.
So I think what happened was it
was just the media picking up
on a narrative that wasn't true.
AUDIENCE: To what
extent do you think
people are fooling
themselves about knowledge
and what they really
consider knowledge?
Like there's a lot
of knowledge in, say,
the third world that probably
isn't thought about very
much in Silicon Valley.
There's knowledge that
is not optimistic,
say unions are seen
as like complaining.
So that knowledge seems
to get discounted.
I think knowledge here
is seen as optimism
and seen as knowledge that's
around Silicon Valley.
Do you think that's true?
Do you think that the knowledge
is really narrower than really
all knowledge, I guess?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: Well, I
think, just philosophically,
the idea that most
folks, when they
start a company or at least
information technology
companies, they have this
kind of general theory
that whatever knowledge they're
putting out into the world
somehow makes it better.
In the case of
Facebook, they believe
that people sharing information
and pictures of their family
would create more
connections between people.
People would develop empathy.
We would be a more bipartisan
nation, things like this.
When it came to Twitter,
the founders of Twitter
told me that it started out
as kind of like an information
broadcasting service, where one
of the founders was on a BART.
And if he experienced
an earthquake,
he would want to let everyone
know that he was OK, right?
So when I say
information, it's tackled
like one product at a time,
and it's one bill at a time.
So the idea of cities building
very dense and tall cities,
the idea is that you can invite
people of all income brackets
into the same area.
They can enjoy the same
schools and job opportunities.
And you can invite smart people
from all over the country
to work in the most
productive companies.
I mean, I'm using knowledge
kind of writ large,
but it's tackled one policy,
one product at a time.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm not sure.
But just to pick up on
the city, so the idea
is people could all
come together in a city.
But the actual reality is
the rentals have gone up,
and so it's people
have to leave the city,
and it's becoming more of
a monoculture in that sense
and in some way.
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: And
that's because San Francisco
systematically refuses
to build more housing.
More people could live here,
if it was denser and taller
and you could
build faster, there
wasn't as much
regulation around.
That would solve, I think,
that monoculture problem.
Seattle, the New York
area, much more diverse,
because a more
diverse set of people
can afford to live there.
And that's why solving the
San Francisco housing crisis
is very core to the technology
political philosophy.
And I will just say this--
thank you for bringing that up--
that if you're interested
in solving the crisis,
you can go to
affordableSanFrancisco.com,
and I am going to be
helping out with others
who are doing campaigns to
actually introduce legislation
that allows San Francisco
to become denser and taller
and build more quickly.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the non-zero sum game
outlook of technologists.
And for things like material
benefit, health care,
that is absolutely true.
But for political power,
there is a fixed amount
of political decision making
which happens in the world.
And disparity in political
agency is growing as well.
This has been complained about
by both the Bernie Sanders
supporters and the
Donald Trump supporters,
this growing populist
movement that
is saying they have no voice
in the governance of the world.
How do you see the growing
power from the politics
of the technologists interacting
with this populist movement?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: What I
see from the civic sector
of startups is trying
to empower more voices.
So if you look at change.org,
Sean Parker's and Matt Mahan's
brigade, what
they're trying to do
is build technologies that
allow people with out much money
to influence politics.
So change.org-- you don't
need to give any money.
All you need to do
is sign a petition.
And if enough people do that,
it gets media attention.
Some people believe
that helped at least
influence the Boy Scouts
decision to accept LGBT scout
leaders.
So I think it is the hope of
many people in Silicon Valley
that their technology will
distribute political influence
more evenly.
AUDIENCE: What
happens when you talk
to people who are not in
Silicon Valley about this who
don't have a favorable view?
How do they react
to this philosophy,
and what do they think of it?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: So I think--
when I say Silicon Valley,
I mean kind of a cultural
movement, so broadly urbanized,
educated professionals.
That's a lot of people.
Not everyone agrees with it, and
everyone has their own issues.
So traditional
Democrats, especially
out of like the
Bernie Sanders camp,
fear inequality of any type.
They think if you are rich and
you're part of a tech company,
inherently what
you're going to do
is just try to empower yourself
and screw everyone else.
And so what they want
to do is they want
to limit technology companies.
They want to slow growth,
whether it's Uber and Lyft,
through regulations
and redistribute
like power and money.
That's generally
the reaction I get.
They do not believe,
or at least they
have a resistance
to believe, that you
can be a big corporation
or a widely used product
and be generally
good for most people.
Power inherently corrupts.
That's kind of the orientation.
And against that, there's
not a lot you can say,
because to be a
popular tech product,
you need to be used
by a lot of people.
To have it be sustainable, it
needs to make a lot of money.
You can win them
over on some issues,
like housing in San
Francisco or education,
if you make education cheaper,
like Udacity and Coursera,
top universities in the
world which were once
reserved for very wealthy
people who could afford Stanford
and Harvard.
Now everyone can take
their classes for free.
So I think on some
issues you'll win
that crowd over--
philosophically probably not,
but on the issues, yes.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: What about rural
conservatives, same question?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN:
Rural conservatives--
maybe just because I don't
have a lot of touch point
with rural conservatives,
but I haven't
seen a lot of complaints
from that camp.
So I don't know.
I have no idea.
If I hear, like if someone
pings me on Twitter and says,
I'm a rural conservative.
I don't like you, then
I'll be able to engage
with that person.
Or if anyone listening online
is a rural conservative,
email me, tweet at me.
We'll have a conversation.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you based a lot of this
on this survey that you did.
Now was there controls?
Because that's somewhat of
self-selection as to who
returns the survey.
Perhaps it was just
all the Libertarians.
Perhaps it was all Democrats.
How did you do
controls for that?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: Well, so you
can't do controls in a survey.
All surveys-- all
political opinion
surveys-- unless you like strap
someone down and torture them
until they answer questions,
are, by definition, voluntary.
What you hope is that you get a
broad enough sample of people,
and that the people who answer
your question-- I guess what
you hope is that the reason why
someone answers your question
is independent of their
political ideology.
So if you believe that if you're
more Libertarian or culturally
conservative you're more
likely to answer any opinion
poll, than yes, it's a problem.
Just speaking kind of broadly
about public opinion polling--
political opinion
polling-- I think
some surveys show
that conservatives
are popular in some
states, and liberals
are popular in other states.
So just answering a
survey seems to be
independent of your
political ideology.
I tried to sample
enough founders.
I sampled about 144.
The margin of error was
about plus or minus 7%.
AUDIENCE: I guess like
historically the Democratic
Party has, I think, of as like
having in mind the concerns
of working class people.
And it seems like this new
movement within the party
seems like very meritocratic
and is OK with inequality.
And how do you see
the future playing out
in terms of like kind
of the Bernie Sanders
camp of the Democratic
Party, I guess,
and the people who
seem to be looking out
for the interest of
working class people
and the more
meritocratic side, that
seems to just want
to empower people
but may not look out for people
who are like super motivated
and driven to capitalize
on those opportunities?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: So that's
a really good question.
I'm glad you asked it.
I'm going to give it a little
bit of a lengthy answer.
But I'll try to keep it short.
So I once thought this ideology
was pretty tied to income.
If you made a lot of money
and you were highly educated,
you tended to
believe this thing.
I was wrong.
I started doing surveys-- thanks
to the Google Surveys team
actually.
They're great-- of gig economy
workers in San Francisco.
I was able to filter
people who worked for Uber
and Lyft an InstaCart
and TaskRabbit.
Gig economy workers
have a political profile
much closer to tech workers,
than people who tell me they're
in a union.
This makes sense.
They have a more
entrepreneurial lifestyle.
They are bigger fans of
high-skilled immigrants
like tech workers, because
help create the products
that give them a job.
On presidential
candidates, they're
bigger fans of Hillary Clinton
than Bernie Sanders, who
potentially could be the
person to regulate technology,
if he ever got to be president,
more so than Clinton.
Because they live an
entrepreneurial existence,
they're more like tech
workers, and they need
a similar role for government.
It turns out that
this has happened
before in Democratic history.
The original
progressives, people
who called themselves
progressives
in the Democratic Party, go
all the way back to 1840.
Originally, the Democratic
Party as a whole
was against free trade.
This was before the United
States had much of a free trade
agreement at all.
And when the government tried
to introduce more free trade
principles, the bill failed.
When the new high-tech
industry of the time
in the 1840s, the railroads,
partnered with low-skilled farm
workers, who wanted to
sell their goods abroad,
they banded together a
high-skilled industry
and a low-skilled industry
to fundamentally change
America's economic stance
to the rest of the world.
This is happening, I
believe, 150 years later,
with tech workers
and gig economy
workers, the same alliance
just different policies.
That was a long answer.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering about
this urban versus rural theme
you have though, because I have
a feeling it's a little bit
too biased towards like high
density big cities and so on.
When you actually
look at the places
where most of the major
innovations are coming from,
I think it's actually suburbia--
University campuses, suburbia,
and so on, and they're
not very dense.
So like obviously
we're at Google.
It's not that urban.
If you look at the
other companies--
Facebook, all the
big heavy hitters,
like even recent ones-- WhatsApp
was Mountain View downtown,
I think.
And if you go further
back, like if you
look at the history
of Silicon Valley,
IBM invented basically just
this corporate campus something
in the South Bay.
And if you look
through the history,
my point is that cities
are not a prerequisite
for-- I mean dense,
high-density cities are not
a prerequisite and probably not
the best place to really move
the need with innovation.
And San Francisco has
certainly some startups,
and I think the
scene has shifted
more toward San Francisco
in recent years,
but I'm not sure of the
cause and effect there.
So maybe you can talk
about this a bit.
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: No,
that's an excellent question.
The idea is that especially
Silicon Valley, when
it started in the '60s and then
kind of grow, '70s and '80s,
tended to be a little
bit more suburban.
So why are cities necessary?
So there's two
responses to that.
One is, relatively
speaking, the Bay Area
is still extremely
dense, compared
to the middle of the country.
Where I'm from, Omaha,
Nebraska and the rest of these,
even though it
doesn't look as dense
because there's kind of
single family home houses,
there's a lot of them.
And no one really has
big yards here, right?
So compared to the rest of
the country and in New York
as well, still relatively dense.
The other argument is that
even if all of the invention
is kind of happening
in the outer suburbs
of major metropolitan regions,
a lot of the technologies
are built for folks living
in cities to solve city
problems-- Google Maps, right?
The idea that you
need to look at a map
because you don't know
where you're going
is a city phenomenon.
When I lived in Omaha,
I didn't need a map.
I knew where I was going.
I went to basically the
same places every day.
Airbnb-- the idea
that you would need
to sleep on someone's
couch-- one,
there would be
enough couches, B,
there would be that
many people to support
an entire industry only
happened because of cities.
So a lot of the new
technology, especially
the sharing economy--
Craigslist-- all
happened because there was so
much complexity and so much
stuff in the system that someone
needed to simplify it and help
people share resources.
In small towns, you can
do that analog style.
You just know everyone.
So that's generally why
cities are important.
On the data side,
economics, there's
a Berkeley professor
named Enrico Moretti.
He calculated that housing
restrictions in three cities--
San Jose, San Francisco, and
New York-- kneecaps national GDP
by 10%, because there's a lot
of talented coders in the world.
If a coder in Oklahoma
can move to Mountain View
and work at Google, they're
are a lot more productive
than any company they're going
to work for in the Midwest.
AUDIENCE: So with
something you said earlier,
kind of alluded to something.
You don't really know that
many rural conservatives.
This is a growing trend.
Not the not knowing of
rural conservatives,
but the ideological
purity of social groups.
Social networks
are growing larger,
but they are becoming
described as echo chambers.
Do you see this is
a trend which is
related to the technologists
continuing, declining?
What do you see the future
path of the composition
of social groups
and how it relates
to what you talked about?
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: I would love
to be optimistic on this one.
I am not.
I do believe that ultimately
people who are optimistic
are going to shape the future.
Hence the presentation.
By the internet is a
very large echo chamber.
If you look at-- let's just
take Donald Trump supporters.
There are websites that cater
to them-- Breitbart.com,
to some extent the
blaze.com, Fox News.
Even though they are incredibly
popular-- tens of millions
of readers, some of the
largest and most powerful news
organizations on the
internet-- they are rarely
quoted by mainstream
media-- "Washington Post,"
"New York Times," and even some
of the more liberal outlets.
An entire movement was
built to elect a president,
and it was considered a joke by
most of the mainstream media.
Not because they
necessarily disagreed,
but because they
had so little touch
with the other half
of the country,
that they didn't even
realize it existed.
If we are to solve this
problem, we will likely
have to bridge those groups.
I don't know how to do that.
That said, still an optimist.
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, on that note,
thank you very much for
speaking with us today,
and we look forward
to hearing more
about your research
in the future.
GREGORY FERENSTEIN: Great.
Thanks, guys, Thanks, internet.